[Musique]
la main ne peut pas être considérée
comme garant la démocratie la démocratie
est censé être garantis par les
institutions qui qu'il incarne donc à
travers le suffrage universel a
travaillé les contre-pouvoirs également
à travers les autorités administratives
indépendantes
l'armée est en réalité n'est pas
nécessairement le garant de la
démocratie mais le garant de
l'indépendance nationale est le garant
de la souveraineté et a pour mission
donc de protéger le territoire de
protéger la population
alors il se fait que bien entendu compte
tenu de ses spécificités
elle peut être amenée à intervenir elle
a été souvent mais intervenir en afrique
en tout cas dans le champ politique et
je pense qu'il ne faut pas considérer
que cela relève de ses prérogatives de
cette voie qu'il faut dix ont banalisé
ces interventions sur la scène même si
dans certaines circonstances bien
entendu elles se justifient elles
peuvent se justifier elle pulse expliqué
mais bien entendu il faut veiller à
ce que les sections de l'ue devienne la
règle
[Musique]
alors ce que démontrent les la fréquence
des coups d'état notamment ces dernières
années en afrique de l'ouest
particulièrement la demande de malaise
de malaise politique de malaise social
cela démontre un peu des limites de la
démocratie si on veut s'arrêter à la
compréhension disons delà de cette
démocratie quelque peu confisquées dans
les régimes présidentiels comme avant
lui qui se sont très largement
présidentialiser au les chefs d'état ont
eu à
à se considérer à être considéré comme
étant finalement des monarques
républicains donc celui-ci de tous ces
malaises là qui qui qui se cristallise
un peu dans ses coups d'état que nous
avons maintenant à répétition en afrique
de l'ouest
alors ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que l'intervention des armées dans
le jeu politique
vient quelque peu
remplacé bien quelqu'un pour se situer
aux institutions de contre pouvoirs qui
sont censés réguler le jeu politique qui
ne le font pas ou qui ne le sont pas
assez bien et donc en réalité ce qu'il
faut chercher à comprendre à améliorer
c'est comment cette démocratie qui est
finalement au service de quelques uns
qui peut aussi se traduit par une sorte
de confiscation du pouvoir comment cette
démocratie là se réinvente et comment
elle se met finalement au service de
l'intérêt général parce que c'est cela
la démocratie c'est cela ce que les
citoyens sûr que les électeurs attendent
donc des citoyens dans le jeu
démocratique où ils sont chacun
considérait comme comme étant égaux donc
dans l'accès aux responsabilités
politiques et dans le choix des
dirigeants bien entendu dans la
configuration actuelle on est dans
beaucoup de pays dans des situations
dans lesquelles cette égalité est cette
possibilité d'accès ressemble et et
n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas garanti
même si du point de vue des lois du
point de vue de la tenue des élections
et des référendums on peut considérer
que que c'est bien le cas mais dans la
réalité ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas
je pense que c'est ce qu'il faut
chercher à compenser ce qu'il faut
chercher à améliorer
[Musique]
alors c'est le retour de la manivelle
parce que quand il ya une logique d
instrumentalisation des armes et qu'il
est qui les éloigne de l'un de leurs
missions premières kantienne logique de
subordination va dire exclusive de
défaut sa mère la seule autorité du chef
de l'état à l'autorité du présent arrêt
pluie qui effectivement le chef suprême
des armées dans le commandement dans la
prise de décision dans les arbitrages
même bien entendu à d'autres
institutions qui sont censés jouer des
rôles le parlement et d'autres
institutions de contrôle a suscité
civile mais aussi chaque citoyen chaque
contribuable qui y contribuent
qui
apporte donc des ressources à
l'équipement des forces armées est à
l'heure au traitement et donc cette
cette caporalisation cette mise sous
coupe désarmés bien entendu montre des
limites montre des limites en ce sens
que la tente que certains dirigeants
peuvent avoir en termes de protection at
vitam aeternam de leur régime cette
attente est bien entendu parfois déçu
parce que les militaires je pas dit
l'armée les militaires ont des systèmes
dans les gens sont multiples comme
chaque citoyen dans la société ils
appartiennent à des familles ils
appartiennent dans d'autres groupes
d'humains et donc ils sont bien entendu
sensible à un certain nombre de sit in
dans la société un certain nombre
d'évolutions de marqueurs politiques
sociaux de la société qui peuvent
expliquer un moment donné qu'ils
puissent prendre la responsabilité de
renverser la table de changer la donne
[Musique]
les armées peuvent être considérés
doivent être considérées doivent se
considérer comme des allées de la
société civile mais dans la pratique
disons que c'est une variable ça dépend
donc du décompte est des situations des
événements des attentes aussi des uns et
des autres mais sur le principe je
considère que l'armée doit être non
seulement l'arrêt de la société civile
aussi l'allié de l'ensemble des corps de
la société l'armée doit être
l'incarnation de l'état de la nation
doit être l'incarnation de ce désir de
vivre ensemble de deux défaites vision
commune qu'on a dans une société dans
une nation dans une dans une partie donc
à doit être acquis distance on va dire
de l'ensemble des forces sociales et
bien entendu
défenseur pour politique pardon est
également mais fait pas toujours le cas
bien entendu c'est pas c'est pas
toujours le cas l armée bien souvent
c'est quand on quand on a eu dans les
années au début des années 90 le début
de démocratisation dans la plupart des
pays d'afrique subsaharienne où on a
considéré que la mettais à retourner
dans la quinzaine et parfois elle a
considéré l'armée les militaires qui
n'était pas de le voit donc
de comprendre les enjeux politiques et
de défendre quelque peu cette cette
incarnation de la nation en armes mais
on a bien vu dans beaucoup de pays où la
situation évidemment sont très
différentes mais dans certains pays tout
particulièrement on a désormais
extrêmement politisée au sens où il ya
une caporalisation une mise sous tutelle
au sens où l'armée n'est pas on ne peut
pas être considérées comme étant les
plus calmes comme étant au service de la
nation et au service de l'ensemble des
composantes de la société dont elle
s'est finalement coupé parfois contenu
des abus des abus qui sont qui sont
parfois signalés dans les opérations qui
sont menées par pas ces armes est là et
pas les services de police également et
donc en afrique on l'afrique de l'ouest
la fête francophone on est encore dans
un cheminement de construction de ces
décès les armées républicaines de ces
entités qui ont qui sont censés incarner
justement à ce
les nations en construction les états en
développement et bien entendu on est
encore un peu loin du compte pour la
plupart des états même si on a bien
entendu beaucoup d'autres beaucoup de
bons exemples dames et république hommes
comme celle du sénégal dab et
professionnels qui sont en mesure de
garantir la neutralité républicaine de
garantir la protection des institutions
et bien entendu de défendre également
donc d'accomplir leurs missions
premières protéger le territoire
protéger les citoyens protéger
l'institution
alors les présidents à vie oui c'est
vrai qu'on statistiquement on en a
beaucoup même actuellement je crois
qu'on a un président qu'on considère
qu'ils n'ont pas requis a pas de plan de
l'alternance qui a pas d'alternative
envisagé produit d'abord dans leurs
propres dans leur propre majorité dans
le propre camp et on a vu effectivement
dans beaucoup de pays des présidents
donc qui sont morts au fil donc des
mandats qu'ils accumulent est qu'ils ont
quelque peu bloqué le jeu politique
bloquée l'alternance se fait à cette
heure c'est un phénomène qu'il faut
qu'il faut interroger à l'aune de
plusieurs variables je pense qu'il ne
faut pas
considéré que la volonté d'un seul homme
le désir de pouvoir le désir de conquête
permanente de conservation du pouvoir
par un homme peut être simplement
réalisé par sa seule volonté je pense
qu'il faut questionner dans les sociétés
l'engagement politique des femmes et des
hommes qui est qui anime le jeu
politique et qui quelque peu prête le
flanc à cet ascète landes dynastique là
qu'on constate dans beaucoup de pays
africains il faut prendre en compte
également cette sorte de file des
institutions de contre pouvoir parce que
vous avez des conseils constitutionnels
vous avez des parlements vous avez plein
d'institutions qui sont créées pour
justement empêcher 7,7
patrimonialisation du pouvoir mais qui
ne joue pas le rôle qu'ils sont bien
souvent en connivence en complicité avec
les pouvoirs exécutifs qui qui en fait
dix ans cette tendance à aux nouvelles
mans infinie je pense qu'il faut
également regarder le la même fight du
côté des intégrations régionales qui
sont
en tant qu ils sont censés promouvoir de
bonnes pratiques mettre en place des
cadres des citations pour que les états
membres puissent se développer de bonnes
pratiques de
du jeu politique de l'offre politique de
façon à ce que les électeurs puissent
comprendre vivre la démocratie comme
quelque chose qui leur procurent
les attentes légitimes qui est que ces
citoyens vis-à-vis donc de de l'étape
[Musique]